so time then for the press preview our
first look at what is on the front pages
as they arrive here at sky we're going
to see what's making the headlines
tonight with the daily mirror columnist
susie boniface and the columnist for the
times and sunday times
matthew syed evening to you both speak
to you in a moment let's see what is on
then some of those front pages
starting with the telegraph leading on
the duchess of cambridge visiting the
tribute to sarah everard on clapham
common
and describing her own fears of walking
in london
at night that's also on the front of the
express the headline there simply
for sarah and in the mail with the
headline kaint
kate joins the vigil for sarah
the observer says the government has
been delused with the personal stories
of
thousands of women who say they've faced
harassment
and are demanding new laws to protect
them
and the staff pays tribute to the
formula one commentator murray walker
who's died at the age of
97.
and i'm joined tonight by susie boniface
and matthew syed great to see you both
this evening thanks for being with us
the paper's really being published a
little bit
too late to get that breaking news in
this evening about the
scuffles the arrests the clashes uh
however you like to describe them that
took place on capham common
this evening matthew we can actually
look at some of the footage now i mean
really
worrying scenes and clearly there is a
huge
political fallout from this
yes i i had some doubts about the
legislation
the risk of transmission when people are
outside is
is quite low so i felt that it was
rather too onerous
and i think a lot of the public felt the
the same way
um these scenes do look extremely
disturbing
i i can certainly understand why people
might draw the
inference from what we're seeing that
the police has been heavy-handed
but i'm a bit old-fashioned you know
sitting and looking at pictures
from where i am in my living room still
pictures that will doubtless appear on
the later editions of the newspapers
i think we should wait and see exactly
what
other people have to say what the
evidence is police testimony the
testimony of people on the ground
to get as much of the context as
possible before we reach a definitive
judgment about what is a politically
highly explosive scenario yeah let's
take a look at the front page of the
observer the headline there going with
pressure grows for new laws
to curb violence against women uh susie
it was always going to be very tricky
this
wasn't it telling people that they can't
go
and have this vigil as they wanted to
um and yet knowing that people probably
would turn up
and we're in the middle of a pandemic
it's very very difficult but you do
wonder why perhaps the police couldn't
just sort of stand back and monitor it
monitor things
this evening um but as matthew says it
it's it's very hard without all the
facts but right
you think the home secretary to call for
this investigation so soon
uh i don't think we need to wait too
long for very many facts because there's
an awful lot of video footage
coming out showing women that are
sitting peacefully at the bandstand
being grabbed and dragged off clapham
common
while they're marking the death of a
woman who was dragged off
clapham common um there doesn't need to
be
a huge inquest or to sit and wait for
the context of that
the context of that is disgusting uh and
it's not we i don't really care whether
it's cressida dick or pretty patel or
anybody whose responsibility is
whoever decided to send the heavies in
needs to go and whoever decided at the
metropolitan police
earlier this week that they would not
engage
with the protesters and would not
discuss with them
the ways that they could hold this vigil
safely and securely
should also go because that decision
would have happened right at the top
somewhere
and whoever decided not to engage to not
put anything in writing as the
organizers have said
and to not sit down with them and all
discuss the way that this could be held
safely
as they did with extinction rebellion
protesters earlier this year
last year as they do the black lives
matter protesters
as they do with football teams regularly
um whoever made that decision is
ultimately responsible for what's
happened here today
and we need to remember that whatever
you think about what's been going on
there at clapham common
there is a mother tomorrow who is
marking mother's day
without her daughter because she was
walking home one night got into
someone's car
somehow and ended up having to be
identified from her dental records
during the course of the week
uh and how does that woman how does that
mother feel
looking at the footage of the women
peacefully marking her daughter's
disappearance
yeah and tragic death yeah and how do
they feel about it
i've got to explain it to my
five-year-old tomorrow it was
international women's day on monday
and here we are before a whole week even
has passed
and women who are peaceful are being
physically dragged away
from marking the death of a woman it's
astonishing
it's tone death it's incredibly
immoral and illogical to even the
complete lack of common sense
whoever is running that operation
actually on the ground
there tonight um but it was peaceful
during the day and i think we should
also remember that
tomorrow and as you know the fallout of
this starts trickling
through people are going to start
briefing and we're going to start
hearing the line
of well the police did ask them to stay
away you know and they did
turn up and they probably shouldn't have
done the police told everybody to stay
away
day and night the future queen of
england
turned up and ignored the police today
kate was there ignoring the police
advice to stay away
and if she can do it then there's no
reason the rest of us can't
well let's talk about that in a bit more
depth then because the front of the
sunday telegraph
uh shows a picture of kate uh her
tribute
as she recalls how it felt to walk in
london
at night herself um of course before she
became
a part of the royal family and
interestingly matthew there's also an
analysis piece here
duchess's flowers have a pointed
political message
for the prime minister she obviously
thought a great deal before she went and
made this very public statement
yeah and and one can fully understand it
because
the amount of testimony that we've heard
this week from
women who have spoken with great
eloquence and poignancy
about not feeling safe uh on the streets
particularly
late at night i mean it has been i think
a wake-up call of a really quite
profound
kind for at least that half of society
that i'm a representative of
um so i think it was a very dignified
visit by
um kate to to to the to the vigil
um but just one thing on on the police
response you might remember
susie rightly pointed out that there has
been some inconsistency
in how the police has responded but you
might remember with the black lives
protests
uh the black lives matter's protest that
the police were severely criticized for
not properly
enforcing the law um and i just think
you know i'm not in any way defending
the police the images that uh susie
described
they are extremely damaging and and and
and chastening and and one feels angry
about them
all i'm saying is that before reaching a
definitive conclusion i mean it's on the
same night that it happened
due process i think requires us to at
least hear
their explanation to probe their
explanation to test it
severely but nevertheless to listen
before making a judgment i've been
i've been shocked on twitter to see the
person currently accused of the crime
being described as a murderer
there is a presumption of innocence in
this country the rule of law
is the most fundamental thing uh that
keeps our society safe we need to
strengthen it in the case
of women's safety for sure but we must
nevertheless
repeat the the mantra the rule of law is
sacrosanct
um i want to be careful not to i want to
be careful not to go
into the details of the case obviously
with someone having been charged but
susie jump back in there is a rule of
law and the rule of law says you
can't be arrested without good reason uh
sitting down
next to a bandstand isn't a good reason
to me even during a pandemic uh it also
says that women should feel safe
walking home and they don't and it says
that we should be able to trust the
police and also that the police
police with our consent um what happened
tonight i don't live in london
i'm not policed by the metropolitan
police anymore i did do a few years ago
but
um this does not happen with my consent
and i'm no barrister
but i'm pretty certain it's illegal to
screw women without their consent
and what's happened today on clapham
common has screwed every woman in this
country
and and we've just got about 30 seconds
before the break but um i want to ask
you both this susie where do you think
we go
uh next uh after what has been a
horrific
week or so i hope
we have a fair trial uh without any
contents of court issues
and that the main suspects uh in the
murder gets his hearing that he should
have and that sarah gets justice that's
the most important
thing i hope that tomorrow everyone
remembers they've all got a mother
yeah yeah you're absolutely right and
matthew you've done uh
a lot of work with with young men with
with boys as well you've written about
it a great deal
and you know education is key to this as
well isn't it
yeah absolutely fundamental um i had a
letter
today an email from my son's school
where the one of the the teaching staff
has said that they
i mean my son is is seven years old i
think it's absolutely crucial
that young men who's a boy he'll become
a teenager
understand the sensitivities understand
that walking too
close to a woman on their own late at
night is completely unacceptable
to understand the constraints that ought
to exist
so that we but the other thing i think
that i'd like to come out with this is
is new legislation
the number of people who are convicted
of crimes when women come forward for
harassment groping and other things of
that kind
is far too low and i think the
government needs to come up with really
clear recommendations of how the law can
be
strengthened to ensure that the law does
its bit
and what i think will be a i hope very
much a big cultural shift
yeah so grim isn't it on so many levels
uh susie
matthew thank you for the moment uh
coming up we're going to be talking
about the death of the formula one
commentator
murray walker that's in a couple of
minutes
welcome back part two of the press
preview still with me daily mayor
columnist susie boniface and economist
for the times and sunday times matthew
syed matthew let's look at the front
page of the daily star
um i mean what what a legend
murray walker was and uh today we've
been
remembering him and watching back some
of the the classic clips
yeah an absolutely fantastic sports
commentator his enthusiasm
uh was infectious he he commentated at a
time when sport was often
covered on terrestrial on network
television and we command
viewing figures above 10 million
sometimes over 20 million
and so these people were not kind of you
know people like murray walker and david
coleman and peter alice who also the
golf commentator who passed away
recently
they were kind of like evangelists
taking sport to people who may have
switched over onto bbc
two without a deep interest in goal for
athletics or formula one
and and i think murray walker was one of
the
iconic figures uh of sport the some of
the
testimonies that have come out in
tribute to him have been
extremely moving from from damon hill
and sir jackie stewart
uh and he will be very sorely missed
yeah and that voice
was just so incredible wasn't it you're
absolutely right we really will
miss him um moving on to the front of
the observer
susie uh collapse of trade with the eu
will last until the summer
yeah uh now if you're pro brexit you
probably call this a wrinkle
and teething trouble and if you're
anti-brexit you'd say this is what you
knew it was going to be like all along
the issue is whether it lasts past the
summer
and whether actually what's going to
happen after this is going to be
structural
of course the the government has
extended unilaterally
some of the border controls until the
summer and of course if you get to the
summer and you've still got this issue
with
both imports and exports being many
billions of pounds lower
than they were this time last year then
whether the government decides to
unilaterally extend them again and how
long they can keep doing that and how
long businesses can keep surviving
matthew i i agree with that completely i
was extremely troubled
by the unilateral extension just as i
was by the breaching of the rule of
law last year trust in
international affairs is of massive
importance
and i think the government is
squandering a commodity that takes
generations to build up
i also agree with susie completely that
if this turns out to be teething
trouble so well and good but it's not
looking that way
um and this i think is going to be
something a story that will run and run
yeah well after what has been a
desperately sad
and miserable week let's end with
something to smile about and as always
matt the cartoonist delivers susie for
the sunday
telegraph uh great little cartoon here
mum you fed me little this is a child
speaking to his mother
mum you've fed me looked after me and
homeschooled me
you really should have remembered to buy
yourself some mother's day
flowers susie yeah and you can tell that
cartoon was drawn by a bloke because
apparently that mum only did three
things for her kid
his whole life left out
teaching him to tie his shoelaces wipe
his own bun
look after him uh go out to work
buy his furniture teach him to do his
trousers up and everything else
let's just make it a morning that's an
average mom's work
get the woman to do the cartoon you'd
find it was a proper list
do you know what this actually happened
to a friend of mine today she said that
she
said to her children anything you need
from the shops i'm nipping out and her
13 year old son said to her oh yeah
could you get some flowers
it's mother's day tomorrow
matthew uh you've got flowers behind you
but if you remember mother's day because
of course we have to remember
our own children doing their mother and
our own mothers as well
well actually i'm glad to say i don't
think my wife is watching
at the moment um i think she's gone to
bed but uh i did
uh post a card if my mother's watching
we did post a card for you and i went
out with our two children today and
you're all sorted for my wife so yeah
we're okay